I'm gonna give you a quiz now we're
gonna do a little quiz oh and then a
reaction okay which one's yours let's do
the clown for a squids Berg who's the
fighter now go for a b and c who says
phrase after each one of his fights
he says the phrase and then what does it
mean you ready sure the phrases and hum
did in that is this Conor McGregor a B
John Jones
C Habib come on it's obviously could be
a little bit John Jones because not John
Jones said it once he said it one he did
not he said it was I'm good sir how you
doing oh man
that is so good alhamdulillah he said it
it's now so you got me you got the first
part so you got fifty ok so what's it
mean now I always say one more time huh
say one more time al hamdulillah and he
is saying alhamdulillah Oh
everything God gave me so again he's
keeping it humble if anything we could
take away from his video is is is that
quality of keeping it humble we got too
much we're all susceptible to an ego the
ego can take over and you become very
arrogant who likes to be around arrogant
people keeping it humble again he's
saying alhamdulillah it's just like
saying thank you God
[Applause]
very simple not you can appreciate that
let's go on to the next thing I'll make
it even easier probably all power to him
or I know he's very religious so he's
probably giving all I'll make it easier
ok
hallelujah praise Jesus
I guess oh praise the Creator God crazy
crazy Pharaoh I'm did a lot equals I try
not to take sides
ya know I love everybody everybody look
for everybody so it's more of a like
praising the creator of the heavens and
earth God Almighty so we got that and
then let's do one reactions ok video ok
this would be one minute of watch and
then we want to get your reaction if
just whatever comes from your heart your
mind whatever feeling
[Music]
[Music]
one bonhomie one is
[Music]
Derby nevermind
all become imagine
well
waitin on everything
I said to lastly I wanna sleep
really cool
[Music]
no banker who
once anyone me
[Music]
we just saw him talk about moral value
and character and is very very poor
yeah I don't know try to listen to more
to get more of a reaction okay so I like
what you said that's this is something
we as human being is just getting to a
whole nother level of morality of
character yeah I can never lose with
that where you mentioned love for
everybody being a good noble character
absolutely that stuff some for him yeah
so do we teach our kids to wrestling you
teach your kids through to Jitsu it man
so everybody pushing their kids right
morals values in character my brother
here Ben Askren I'm the deso
all right so you guys are probably
wondering why mail keeps wearing this
shirt he has like a hundred copies of
the show right hundred but how many he
has a lot of what a few quite a few so
he's not wearing the exact same shirt
okay I don't want people to think that
you're wearing the same shirt all the
time every so every picture you see he
goes from the highest point to the
lowest just humbling himself
you know keeping it humble because a lot
of times some of you get to make a lot
of money a lot of fame and you become
arrogant we go haughty so the idea with
salah the prayer right here as you're
saying
prayer just humbling yourself keeping it
humble putting your forehead on the big
ground many people meditate it's kind of
form of meditation but at a whole nother
level keep it at humble thanking the one
who created us for giving all these
blessings the one guy the same guy that
Jesus Moses Abraham prayed to does the
Bible train - and the last Defense
Department peace be upon him peace be
with you so I'll make